eh bien bon jour bien joujou son côté
donald et v6 tout chaud c'est tout chaud
kramnik est champion du monde unifié
will a battu topalov au départage pour
ce qui enlève toute problématique de
suspicion est alors pour cette émission
est un peu spécial pour cette victoire
de devenir chronique je reçois un invité
inhabituel c'est séverine bennama
bonjour séverine séverine et images à
stéphane alors comment savoir
mais ça va bien merci alors c'est vrai
que c'est une belle a battu et tué l
intéressé par le jeu d'échecs depuis
depuis à peu près depuis à peu près un
an j'ai découvert à peu près le jeu
d'échecs l'année dernière je suivais
d'ailleurs championnats du monde à saint
louis ce je suivais les parties
particulièrement de judit polgar les je
participe donc à aux organisations des
grands prix des chèques d'aix en
provence et de bordeaux voilà donc plus
tôt spécialisé dans les médias c'est ça
quant à l activité communication
autour des médias alors qu'est ce que tu
connais du jeu d'échecs finalement
qu'est-ce que tu retiens de déchets
reste un jeu c'est un jeu qui est
passionnant je retiens qui m'a appris
beaucoup de patience on va dire quand et
amateurs on va dire que la lutte un
débat ni grand maître maintenant pas du
tout j'ai découvert six joueurs de
claudine jour de clopes simplement pas
sur internet uniquement voilà et donc tu
suis ce championnat bon en vidéo évident
tu participes évidemment la rédation ce
programme et de sa réalisation et ses
amis tu suis aussi donc tu as suivi
s'ils ont besoin du monde un peu en
vidéo alors qu'elle quel effet ça te
fait de suivre ça parfois de ta vie tu
suis [ __ ] le geste frappé l'animal à
battre est très particulier avec cette
fameuse affaire des toilettes 90 ans
donc on va voir donc mais quelques clics
oui mais qu'est ce que tu en penses que
quelle image tu vois on reçoit enfin
quelques ressentiments tu vois comme ça
c'est sur ce championnat du monde un peu
un peu particulier c'est un match c'est
un match et cette histoire de suspicion
et toi et que tu en penses quoi se
trouve ça normal anormal m'a pas étonné
en fait d'accord donc je trouve que ça
fait ça fait partie du jeu ça fait
partie du jeu que c'est que c'est un peu
les intimidations enrichi qu'est qu'on
peut retrouver dans d'autres sports
finalement voilà d'autres mots peut-être
sur le jeu d'échecs sur sur l'intérêt
que le jeu ben c'est un jeu qui
développe beaucoup de qualités
notamment là je parlais de patience de
prise de décision des deux multitude ya
énormément de choses à apprendre et à
découvrir dans ce jeu je pense que c'est
un jeu qui est vraiment complet alors
pourquoi les femmes arrivent pas c'est
une bonne question mais je pense qu'il
faut beaucoup travailler
mais bon il ya beaucoup de femmes qui
arrivent qui arrive à avoir un niveau
podium derrière il ya de plus en plus de
femmes qu'on va dans le sens c'est
mignon oui les jeunes notamment on a vu
une jeune chinoise récemment de 12 ans
qui progresse donc c'est en train de
devenir peut-être parce que les
conditions matérielles aussi son
meilleur qu'à une certaine époque aussi
sans doute alors on va venir ce
championnat du monde on va on va voir
ces dernières parties de départage donc
ça s'est décidé au départage on peut
vous dire tout de suite c'est kramnik
qui l'a emporté mais alors sur le fil
vous allez voir la fin est tout à fait
extraordinaire est en tout cas bon mais
on peut dire que ça va ça va un peu
effacé ce problème de toilettes etc
si topaloff avait gagné ça aurait pu
durer encore six mois un an deux ans
avant qu'on arrive à trouver à se mettre
d'accord
je pense que là c'est incontestable
topalov a perdu à la fois dans le match
on avait eu si on exclut la partie qui a
gagné par forfait mais déjà il était
nominé et là dans les départage bombay a
clairement en plus donc la terreur mais
je pense que si total of perry perd nos
contrées débilité également oui hyper
hyper un peu idiot il y perd
effectivement beaucoup en crédibilité de
cette ressource match c'est clair qu'il
aura perdu à la fois le titre est sans
doute peut-être des invitations dans les
futurs tournois en tout cas il ya des
les organisateurs déjà qu'on proposait
de boycotter topaloff
non c'est pas ce que ça va donner mais
bon en tout cas c'est une rixe s'est pas
toujours il faut peut-être penser des
fois ce que ou conséquence après match
quoi de faire ce genre d'action enfin
bon en tout cas c'est fait on va voir
tout de suite la première partie de ces
des portages voilà donc très de
transition a proposé par la régie sur
cette première partie entre topalov et
kramnik eh bien on n'y coupe pas
séverine comme tu as pu le voir la
défense l'a caractérisé effective à b4
voilà des 5 c 4 et enfin le petit coupon
la soucoupe ion qui qui changent du
d'où l'ouverture qui est aussi ce qui
correspond ici en gambie sidam serpent
quand on donne ce pion et qui ya le
problème de d'enfermer un peu ce fou
alors dans la slave l'avantagent de
jouer le coup ci c'est aussi de pouvoir
libérer ce fou tard tout en permettant
le contrôle du pion des cinq sur la
menace du pion ses cadres alors on a
déjà parlé plein de fois on va avoir
très vite évidemment c'est les parties
rapides on va voir les quatre dans la
même émission
donc on va papa c'est surtout et coup on
va simplement regarder comment ça s'est
passé en partie rapide ne peux pas
commenter énormément de choses à froid
évidemment en direct on aurait pu
commenter beaucoup de choses mais à
froid il vaut mieux passer rapidement
sur les moments cruciaux de la partie
donc la chronique a choisi de prendre
ces quatre au quatrième coup qu'on mène
le voir donc
il dévie un peu des parties précédentes
où il avait joué le kung fu et 5
voilà donc là mais c'est les parties
rapides encore une fois c'est plus la
préparation qui va jouer 25 minutes par
joueur ça peut se décider très vite faux
et 5 lots jicky si on contrôle le centre
on empêche la pousser le cadre de trois
donc on libère le fou comprendre le pion
c'est tout ça est très classique
on est dans un début de partie classique
ou des quatre petits rock développement
normal cavaliers b17 alors on dit b
cavale et b17 parce que les deux
cavaliers peuvent elles en déceptions
aussi on revient ici
si on dit simplement cavaliers 17 si on
écrivait cavaliers 17
eh bien on pourrait dire cavalli f17
celui qui est sur la colonne f
cette colonne ci ou cavaliers b17 ce que
celui ci aussi peut aller en dix-sept
donc il quand on note les parties on
précise cavaliers b17 pour préciser
lequel des deux va sur la classe 17 dans
me2 logique on augmente la force pour
jouer le coup à 4
c'est une chasse et souhaité prendre le
centre petit rock et là tout de suite
d'ailleurs eu quatre ans là ça y est on
attaque le fou donc logique rien à dire
pour l'essentiel win c'est ça te paraît
logique les coups alors fou g6 fou des
trois fois jusqu'ici clouage du cavalier
en sur madame ici la crainte opale of
pardon choisi un coup agressif en jour
le 5 5 aux responsables toujours de
jouer la structure de pions il attaque
le cavalier tout ça doit être très connu
on a toujours être dans la théorie
calais des cinq cavaliers prend des cinq
échanges de topalov et kramnik choisi de
prendre ces prenez 5 contexte un coût
qui garde une structure de pions qu'on
appelle symétrique puisque là on a une
structure ici symétrique avec celle ci
donc ça ça a plané un tout petit peu la
position plus que si on a des prix de
l'option avec des poussées possible pour
les blancs ans le 6 donc qui semblait
d'ailleurs pas possible donc il vaut
mieux prendre c'est prendre des 5 est
maintenant temps pas jouable trois lits
des dames 3 c'est simplement de sortir
le cavalier du clonage façon à libérer
ce cavalier par exemple pour venir à eux
et poussé f4 et f5 avec le fou ici pour
attaquer contre le roi pour huit
cavaliers
d'ailleurs c'est ce que je jouais pas
l'ofs évidemment j'ai révisé un peu la
partie mais c'est tout chaud hein parce
que le championnat vient de se terminer
il ya une heure pour ses 8 et maintenant
enfin le fameux coup et 4 donc voilà
donc on a enlevé le cavalier maintenant
on voit bien que la dame est plus
attaquées par le fou dont l'idée d'avoir
joué la dame ici et maintenant un plus
car il est enlevé la tour étant des rats
le pion ceux qui ont peu avancé avec
l'idée de jouer un f5 est de créer une
rupture contre cette chaîne depuis la
fameuse chaîne de pions défensive ici
qu'il faut casser de façon à ouvrir la
colonne de la tour qui taperait du côté
du roi voilà c'est toujours très logique
tout ça donc la chronique choisit
d'abord dans un premier temps d'échangé
ici le cavalier fin avec sont fous sont
fous étaient pas tellement actif
ils échangent contre un cavalier bon
pourquoi pas ce que paris aurait pu
rebondir sur la case f3 et ensuite venir
angers 5 créant des menaces avec le fou
par exemple son âge c'est donc pour
prendre
on aurait pu reprendre donc soit de la
tour soit de la dame
évidemment la dame est bien placée en
eux trois on prend de la tour ou g6
fouet fin donc ils préfèrent taux
peuvent garder ses pièces pour l'attack
il veut profiter du fait que ce fou
peut-être et un an ferme et peut-être il
veut jouer g4 et f5 pour enfermer second
tour ces deux maintenant deux chroniques
et sa tour maintenant de vie active
attention puisque la tour de kramnik est
active sur la deuxième rangée protégé
par le fuji 6 donc c'est toujours
embêtant d'avoir une tour comme ça sur
la deuxième b 3-2 topalov damas 5
attention petit oeil sur la tour elle
est défendue pour la dame par la dame
pour l'instant mais ça pourrait être un
thème un petit oeil sur la tour ici par
l'adam fou b5 alors la khl oil ici du
cavalier qui peut pas bouger à cause de
la tour qui est derrière et le câble est
en prise qu'il faut trouver un coup tout
simplement kramnik joue le coutour des
vite ils protègent les cavaliers noter
qu'à ce moment là du match on est on est
dans une partie rapide
il faudrait aussi tenir compte du temps
alors on n'a pas le décompte de temps
exact sur la partie mais la tension va
s'accélérer parce qu'il va rester
maintenant quelque chose comme une
douzaine de minutes à chaque joue l'un
pour eux deux de topalov qui propose un
échange des tours travnik ici choisi de
jouer le coutour c'est ses huit donc de
revenir à la maison
voilà tout simplement alors à noter
qu'ici quand la bulle et blanc donc on
depuis les change un peu
travnik a fait du fou contre le car ils
ont la fameuse paire de fou on en a
parlé déjà dans l'émission notamment
dans ce championnat du monde la paire de
foot toujours un avantage en finale
surtout si la position s'ouvre en
l'occurrence elle est un peu fermé ici
les chaînes de pions sont bien solides
mais si par exemple les blancs arriver à
jouer
g4 et f5 posant des problèmes à secouer
ouvrant la position cette paire de fou
peut devenir un avantage décisif
donc attention potentiellement avantage
aux blancs fou des deux attaques la dame
il faut la boue gêne évidemment
chronique jouant b6 garde un petit oeil
sur le pion des quatre qui est quand
même un tout petit peu faible c'est la
base de soutien du pion 5 lui-même n'est
pas protégé par un pion tour f 2 à 6
attaque le moment là c'est facile fouet
fin on revient fallait trouver où il
veut pas échangé son compère celui ci
parce qu'il veut profiter de ce fou qui
peut être mal placé pour ces 6 et là
maintenant des quatre lots topalov donc
qui va sans doute chercher à jouer b5
protégé par son fief un attaquant à six
et la tour c 6 tours ces deux et
maintenant beesan quand même voilà ça y
est topalov essayer de gagner de
l'espace ici à lille dame à 5 pouces et
3 de topalov maintenant l'idée c'est
d'échanger les tourangeaux peuvent
choisir d'échanger les tours il estime
qu effectivement à raison cette tour est
très active
celle ci l'était beaucoup moins c'est
toujours intéressant d'être d'échanger
une pièce non active avec une pièce
active alors évidemment c'est vrai tu
peux intervenir si tu as une question
sur une position
j'essaie d'y répondre à l' or pourpre en
f2 me suis teint apporte un appareil
très vite ça déroule vite sur ces les
parties rapides sont peut pas aller très
sont très lents en plus on peut pas tout
commenté de façon les joueurs eux-mêmes
avec quelques minutes pour jouer chaque
coup
donc on peut pas commenter de la même
profondeur évidemment qu'une partie une
partie longue d'emprunt f2 damas 7 est
maintenant d'amd dehors tout de suite
c'est le pion à 5 alors voilà on va
rentrer maintenant dans une pression des
blancs sur le côté dames du fait que de
ce pur à 5 est avancé comme b6 est
envisageable mais s'affaiblir et cette
case puisque cette case est protégé par
un pion et donc ça permettrait aux
blancs et de venir sur en c1 et
d'essayer de créer une pénétration c6
alors qu'on voit que les pions ici blanc
et noir contrôler toutes les cases de
pénétration et ce cavalier lui ne
pourrait rien faire il serait
complètement passif donc les blancs
auraient réussi à gagner un gros gros
avantage des espaces ça devient très
délicat pour les noirs qui sont en
défense veut véritablement défense c'est
pourquoi kramis joue le coutour à 8
il veut pas affaiblir cette case c6 il
veut pas jouer les six pour protéger son
pion à 5 mais c'est très passif sur ces
deux pièces encore une pièce courtrai
passible même si la dame est un peu
active puisqu'elle a un oeil sur le sur
le plan des 4 tout ça est très passif et
pose des problèmes ils réservent aussi
la case b6 à son cavalier parce qu'il
veut sans doute crâne il a mené sur la
cascade par exemple vont l'apprécier lui
donner de l'air voilà une possibilité
mais surtout éviter de s'enfermer par le
groupe des six tours c'est un autre pas
l'offre logique cette autorité pactiv
maintenant elle s'active sur une colonne
ouverte possibilité de pénétrer le camp
ennemi et au bon moment travnik joue
cavalier les six mois c'était vraiment
impératif de jouer ce coup dans ce
cavalier peut avoir de l'air alors qu'il
est totalement passif en 17
totalement dominés par les pions
centraux maintenant il a une petite case
de d'espoir ici et surtout tout de suite
il titille le pion à 4 voilà donc menace
était allé prendre à quatre avec un pion
passé noir est d'ailleurs topalov lui
laisse faire avec four b2 est ce que ça
ne serait pas une erreur ici de topalov
de laisser cramique prendre prendre ce
pion mais voilà mais ici oui alors c'est
vrai tu me montre que le pur à 5 et en
prix mais il ya deux défenseurs il ya
deux attaquants il ya aussi deux
défenseurs four b2 topalov laisse
prendre le purin car voilà donc taillé
cramique quand même c'est créer un petit
pion passé il est évidemment coincé mais
c'est plus pareil maintenant que le pion
à 4 a disparu puisque si ce pion à 5
arrive à bouger un peu ça y est c'est
pièces ont une raison d'être c'est
soutenir l'avancée du pion jusqu'à
d'amour fou à 3h 6-2 kramnik petite
fenêtre pour le roi s'est jamais aussi
pour le fou au cas où ils soient
attaqués beaucoup d'attentes topaloff
est aussi un petit coup d'attentes
il était enfoui 4 la ccra mix entre
alice sont fous il est beaucoup mieux
passé évidemment quand j'ai 6 puis qu'il
compte continuer à contrôler cette
colonne et un peu cette scène là aussi
aux h2k et b6 maintenant kramnik ramène
son caviar v6 pour pousser son pion à
voile à m'aimer mais il ya quand même
souci c'est le coup de topalov bien vu
fous ces cinq puisque la lecavalier est
cloué mais de notre côté on voit mal
comment les blancs peuvent augmenter la
pression sur ce cavalier puisque le pion
b5 ont fait bloc
évidemment ça les patients nous comptons
b1 enfin pas tomber un puisqu'il est le
fouet dans les dames les deux plus tôt
et bien le cas elle serait pris jeudi
s'il bouge évidemment il y avait la dame
derrière donc ça aurait été un gros gros
soucis
mais en l'occurrence il ya un bios et
donc on voit pas comment les blancs
pourraient augmenter la pression sur ce
cavalier de la même façon sur 7 sur la
diagonale ici elle est bouchée par le
client des cadres donc on peut pas
rajouter une dame qui ferait pression
sur le cavalier non plus donc c'est
embêtant ce clouage puisque la dame peut
pas bouger si elle bouge le cavalier
perdu le cavalier peut pas bouger
puisque la dame serait perdu
c'est embêtant mais c'est pas c'est pas
décisif à 4 92 chronique alors ça donne
déjà tout de suite un peu d'air et puis
surtout bon mais voilà ce pion commença
à venir un être dangereux donc tu auras
un de topalov logique il essayait
d'arrêter le pion et là maintenant voilà
on va on arrive dans la fin de cette
recette de cette première partie tendue
où les blancs avec un avantage à ce que
cette paire de fou ils ont laissé quand
même prendre ce pion à 4 et la chronique
va trouver
voilà effectivement c'est win tu veux
montrer donc tu proposes quel groupe et
ses quatre enfants crise et la dame en
fait qu'elle et ses quatre pour viser en
sachant que tu as dame est attaqué par
le fou alors voila mais ça c'est
effectivement ça propose un échange
d'armes et voilà voilà effectivement ce
cas l'idée qu'a eue kramnik et on va
voir les allées elle est quand même bien
vu et elle lui permet de totalement
égaliser une position où il est en
désavantage or je vois qu'en régie ça
rigole pas mal
il n'y a pas de quoi pas de quoi cavaler
c42 cramique alors ça a l'air d'être un
coup aux faux puisqu'on se dit oui alors
effectivement madame est attaqué alors
si je prends la dame on peut le voir
tout de suite
effectivement si je prends la dame est
tout simplement les noirs se venge sur
la dernière ce et bien il peut y avoir
il peut y avoir un souci un souci pour
les blancs que faire que faire de ce fou
déjà si le fou par exemple revient ici
mais tout simplement on peut quand même
joué le coup à trois puisque le cas le
fou ici étant prises donc un échange ici
permettrait car il prend fu et une carte
d'un cadeau tout reprend ça serait
emprise donc le pion qui viendrait très
très dangereux menace de jouer à deux et
ensuite cavalier b3 avec perte de la
tour si on joue un coup comme tour à
deux c'est pas possible puisque le câble
étant pris le foot emprise enfin voilà
ça c'est un gros gros gros soucis donc
on voit que c'est pas c'est pas possible
on peut pas l'oeuvre vous probablement
ce qui reste le seul coup mais quitte en
bons coups fou prend ses cadres
j'élimine lecavalier et maintenant je
veux dire états d'âme et attaqué j'ai
pris un cavalier tu enlèves ta dam et
j'ai gagné une pièce mais non mais non
granik a tout vu donc là il fallait
qu'il soit quand même très précis
puisqu'ils jouent le coup b6 laissant de
fou attaqué par les pions donc il
récupère sa pièce voilà on est en
proposa une double attaque maintenant
topalov choisi dames 3 et la chronique
ne s'emballe pas il prend pas tout de
suite la pièce ici en c5
ce qui me permettrait aux blancs de
prendre en c5 puisque maintenant si les
noirs prennent en c4 je prends le fou
monnaie et donc hélas j'ai deux pions
passé lié très fort qui menacent d'aller
à dame donc chrome ne craque pas il
prend pas tout de suite le
le fou n'est pas pressés puisque la
prise est tout de suite encore possible
des deux côtés donc il joue le coutour
c8 tranquille voilà maintenant il dit si
tu sors ton fou je prends ici le fou non
pas avec le pion pardon parce qu'il
faudrait emprise mais avec à tour
maintenant fouet fin et lappion prend
6,5 et on va voir que cette combinaison
de cramique va réussir à tenir la partie
après pions français 5 dans le procès
cinq grammy propose des changes de dames
topaloff est quasiment obligé d'accepter
cet échange et dames puisque dans les
fous sont maintenant très fort mois que
ce fou le site très fort et le pion des
5 es passé peut pousser pour aller faire
dame donc échange de dames tout reprend
6,5 et là on se dit mais les bleus ont
finalement au bout de la combinaison ils
ont quand même un gros pions passé b6 et
menaces p 7b huit dames comment arrêter
ce pion tragique a tout vu pour ces six
tout simplement
j'attaque le pion et on voit que ce pion
est difficilement défendable si je joue
tour b 1 eh bien il faut ici qui prend
la torah et si je joue
pardon ce qu'on veut ce qui a été joué
dans la partie alors à noter que surtout
reprend à 4 tours prend pions il n'ya
pas le mat du couloir ici puisque le roi
ces ménages et les petites fenêtres
donc on a vu on voit l'utilité de ce
genre de coups qu'on a signalé tout à
l'heure donc ici 17 menace de faire
d'abord là il faut l'arrêter tout de
suite mais c'est tranquille pour kramnik
pour des six il a tout vu voilà ça y est
jared champion en titre fait dame je la
prends et voilà comment avec le kenya
topalov trouve encore une petite astuce
pour essayer toujours de garder
l'avantagé à 6 joli coup de topalov
dernière tentative
maintenant si tu reprends fous je fais
dames avec échec au roi les chroniques
il est pas fou il a tout vu encore une
fois des quatre très jolie de chroniques
donc il fallait voir cette combinaison
depuis tout à l'heure
depuis le coup car lycées 4 maintenant
c'est le fou ici qui attaquent le pion
bessette voilà l'idée de coups des
quatre tout simplement c'est pas
tellement d'aller à dame ce qui va être
il va facilement être arrêtée ce pion
par la tour et le fou mais c'est surtout
de récupérer l'eau qui ont 17 qui lui
est très dangereux puisque les blancs
menacé tour c1 avec tours c8 échec au
roi et dames donc tout simplement
maintenant topalov doit rentrer dans la
combinaison qui simplifie tout reprend
1,4 fou prend bessette fou prend 17
tours prendre 17
tout prend des cadres et c'est nul nul
entre les deux joueurs
une partie une partie tendue on peut
dire que kramnik a eu chaud quand même
ils étaient prémédités sous pression et
ils arrivent ils arrivent à s'en sortir
alors est-ce qu est-ce que séverine
comme ça quand quand on est quand on est
amateur quand tu disais tu suivais les
parties du dit paul gars tu as tu as
découvert jc les tigers étaient les
parties longues et donc je passé
plusieurs heures à regarder les parties
en direct
est-ce que tu arrives à deviner les
coûts des joueurs de jeux j'essayais ça
marche et des x ou bats peut souvent
être alors voilà donc à première partie
de départage qu'on mène le voir donc
tendue
mais on va voir ce n'est pas la plus la
plus tendue de ce match alors cédé
partage se déroule en quatre parties
rapides c'était le meilleur des quatre
parties rapides et en cas d'égalité au
bout de 4 à partir
il ya alors deux blitz de liste de cinq
minutes par joueur plus 10 secondes par
coup je crois et enfin en cas d'égalité
encore au bout des 2 d2 blitz un blitz
mort subite habite à la mort subite
c'est six minutes pour les blancs 5 pour
les noirs mais obligation aux blancs les
pleins de gagner voilà il faut qu'ils
gagnent voilà exactement
c'est une sorte d'ultime penalty en fait
voilà pour essayer départager les
joueurs donc ça
à l'issue d'un beast mort subite on
connaît en gagnant passe quand même en
cas de particules et baisser les noirs
qui sont déclarés gagnants
on n'en est pas là ça c'était la
première partie départager enregistre 3
à noter que pour ce match qui était en
12 parties longues
il y avait des prix donc on a on a eu
des mails notamment de nos abonnés
puisque le terminal télé maintenant à
des abonnés c'est de plus en plus
nombreux à vous abonner à l'émission
bien vous habite à en parler autour de
vous aussi et puis la proposer à vos
amis de s'abonner plus on sera nombreux
plus on fore on pourra faire des
missions c'est vrai ça
eh bien nous demandait justement des
informations sur les prix et bien sûr
les prix du match c'était tout
simplement un million de dollars 1
million de dollars proposé par et biens
illicites à la capitale de la kalmoukie
qui est aussi le pays dont le président
est le président de la fide d'albon mais
voilà c'est comme ça
il est aussi président de la kalmoukie
donc saleh d' être à la fois président
et sponsors ce qui reste souvent
d'ailleurs
un million de dollars est en fête qui a
partagé mais à part égale quel que soit
le résultat du match voilà donc c'était
les prix
c'est comme ça parce que ils ont estimé
que bon c'est un match de réunification
qu'il y avait d'un côté un championnat
classique d'un côté un champion de fils
et que et que voilà bon mais les deux ne
voulait pas céder sur sur beau être
d'accord il s'est dit ça leur importait
peu de gagner plus ou moins que cinq
cent mille dollars bon il aurait pu
faire 60 40 mais ce que ça aurait fait
vraiment une grosse différence
bon voilà ils se sont mis d'accord pour
ses cent mille dollars de chaque côté
quel que soit le résultat bon voilà bon
d'un côté sur montceau nous proposer ça
je pense ici à chacun en soit d'accord
ou pas d'accord sur tout pour perdre
voilà donc alors on va passer on va
passer maintenant deuxième partie de
ceux des partages juste je me remets la
partie au début donc deuxième partie
cette fois c'est cramé qu'elle est blanc
donc encore une fois c'était rapide
c'était match partie rapide qu'on le
fait rapidement on va pas rentrer dans
les détails
trop trop technique sur cette conclusion
deuxième partie kramnik à les blancs on
démarre toujours avec des cats
voilà toujours pareil donc qu'est ce
qu'on pense comme ça que ces matches où
il joue toujours même à bernard me
change parce que je regardais toujours
eu quatre donc d'accord en juillet cela
va maintenant que tu penses que tu vas
arriver à jouer les cela tu as compris
les idées qui est derrière
je vais essayer face je ferai quelques
blitz et je te dirai sa prochaine alors
à noter à noter pendant que je vois que
la régie fait des superbes fondu à noter
que
tu as organisé une simultaneously avec
laurent frayssinet c'est un fait le 26
septembre
donc on a fait laurent fessiers donc à
jouer contre des chefs d'entreprises
donc à l'espace horizons à
ozoir-la-ferrière d'accord contre 13
personnes qui l'a emporté 3-0
très facile ou renforcer des très forts
évidemment non seulement meilleur joueur
enfin un des meilleurs joueurs français
les champions de france des champions de
france et il fait partie maintenant on
peut dire hors des meilleurs choix
les meilleurs joueurs du monde un effet
70e au dernier classement il ya déjà été
classée dans les 50 premiers je crois et
il est passé dans l'émission récemment
d'ailleurs on va on va aussi rappeler
ici que vous pouvez vous abonner sur le
site officiel de diagonale des gonades
tv.com vous pouvez vous abonner à la
newsletter de diagonale qui est
importante puisqu'elle va vous donner
des informations sur sur le contenu des
émissions et aussi les offres les offres
spéciales un peu avant tout le monde
quoi sert donc voilà c'est il faut il
faut vaut mieux être abonnés cette
newsletter si vous voulez avoir
l'information en priorité voilà donc on
vous invite à vous inscrire c'est
gratuit sur le site officiel avec une
halte tv.com voilà vous remettez votre
mail dans la newsletter et vous serez
tenu au courant voilà alors on va
revenir sur cette deuxième partie qui
partagent donc le match est tendu
départage parties nulles donc un demi
partout pour l'instant on est à 1/2
partout je le note et on y va des quatre
des cinq c4 et c6 encore une slave
je crois qu'on n'en sortira pas c'est le
match des slams voilà d'ailleurs mes
chroniques et cela une et russe topalov
aussi un peu chez lui doit avoir du sens
la bulgarie doit maintenant les doigts
en avoir aussi donc c'est pas étonnant
qu'à l'e3 qu'alexis calais c 3e 6 donc
alan une semi slave comme l'expliqué
laurent frayssinet eu trois cas les bd
cette dame c'est 2 voilà donc tout ça
est classique mais la dame ici sur une
belle case et le contrôle quatre
peut-être pour plus tard jouer le
la percée de 4 elle est bien placée ici
en c2 fou des six baies 3 des chroniques
qui la joue tranquille petit rock fouet
2 et la b6 de topalov alors un normal
aussi c'est un coût normal on veut
sortir ce fou donc peut-être sur a6
pourquoi pas pour faire pression sur ces
4 et voir s'échanger contre le fu 2 ou
alors plus sagement peut-être sur sur
bessette pour avoir un contrôle sur le
centre c'est logique mais on voit quand
même que ce fou sera un peu enfermé tant
que les noirs ou en page où il a percé
ces cinq peut faire plus tard évidemment
petit rock food et 7 ça je m'en fous des
deux tours 8
logique en mines tours ici pour la
percée thématique c'est quoi la percée
thématique d'un esclave pour les noirs
et bien c'est le coût 1,5
voilà une fois que le centre est est
stabilisé eh bien on va percer au centre
par le simple pour échanger ce pion
contre pion central et on voit que cette
case 2,5 et très bien contrôlé par les
noirs maintenant par la tour aussi par
le cavalier et par le fou voilà donc une
idée de ce qui est important aux échecs
et les danses et le centre donc il faut
percer au sein très souvent soit tenir
le centre soit le contrôler à distance
wallon le bloquer le bloquer pour
ensuite travailler tranquillement sur
les ailes tours a des seins de
chroniques
donc là tranquille mais une tour
derrière son bureau en prévision d'une
poussée centrale et bien sa tour sera en
vis-à-vis avec la dame adverse mais ça
peut toujours être utile
c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs topalov tout
de suite développe saddam en recettes
empêchant son vis-à-vis et est
maintenant il met une deuxième tour me
david adam clasicos il ya beaucoup de
caisses mais évidemment si on cherche à
échanger
il y en aura - et ça peut jouer ça peut
jouer un rôle tour à ses 8 et bientôt
palau fait de la mimine tour en
vis-à-vis de la dame foot est roi
petit oeil ici batterie petit oeil sur
la cades h7 alors ses protégés pour
l'instant par le le cas relève 6 mais
c'est un petit oeil qui peut avoir son
importance aux cinq sens et c'est
l'heure pour topalov il perce au centre
vous allez voir la partie et langue
aussi les parties rapides peut se jouer
beaucoup plus long
beaucoup plus de coups que les parties
longues puisque le temps va être un
facteur déterminant même si la position
est égale le temps va jouer et là
kramnik choisit alors là c'est peut-être
un peu la première fois du match ou
cramique 1 joue pas trop tranquille
carrément lui aussi il attaque au centre
alors là ça fait une explosion de
possibilités des changes pour les noirs
et aussi pour les blancs on le voit ici
avec toutes ces possibilités des changes
il faut faire des calculs énorme pour
savoir ce qui va se passer
à savoir que les blancs semblent avoir
quand même l'avantagé d'avoir une tour
en vis-à-vis des dames nord donc on va
voir ce qui se passe et on prend ces
quatre voilà déjà tout de suite ils
empêchent ce pion évidemment de sortir
pour avoir la tour en vis-à-vis de la
dame
donc c'est sans doute un coup qui était
qui était nécessaire de la part des
noirs rien que pour cette raison là
évidemment de forêt rentrer dans le
détail des calculs mais on va pas le
faire là encore une fois c'est une
position extrêmement explosive et
compliqué notez d'ailleurs c'est le
premier en charge de la partie puisque
pour l'instant tous les pions sont là
toutes les pièces sont là il y avait
encore aucun échange fou prend ses
quatre donc la cram igp rendu fou et non
pas du pion pourtant habitué on a
l'habitude de dire qu'il faut ramener
les pions vers le centre mais là si on
avait ramené le pion vers le centre on
ira à fermer une foule on aurait oui
d'abord
le foot un peu enfermé mais c'est pas
tellement ça c'est surtout qu'après la
prise en d4 on voit que ce pion est tout
seul un peu isolé et
que ce pion ici maintenant va avoir du
mal aussi à avancer puisque la classe de
5 et très bien protégé
et voilà c'est le souci c'est que ce
plan est un peu tout seul et le fou du
coup et actif alors en prenant du fou
ici en plus bombée on met quand même
l'accent sur cette petite diagonale qui
peut être dangereuse avec le rwanda
déjà par exemple une menace peut être
car et les g5
donc il faut il faut réagir et
d'ailleurs ce que fait tout de suite
topalov puisqu'ils jouent bessèges voilà
donc ils empêchent cette menace
potentielle de d'arrivée même si il y
avait peut-être des réponses donc b5
attaque le fou maintenant fouet fin g62
topaloff
alors un petit coup qu'ils contrôlent
ici ces cases blanches mais qui
affaiblit bon classique aller 4 noir bon
il ya encore le fou donc on peut on peut
défendre
donc ça c'est un coût qui fait donne
petite fenêtre aura aussi c'est un coût
qui n'était peut-être pas nécessaire
mais parfois il faut jouer vite en
partie rapide donc on n'a pas toujours
le choix d'amd 2-2 kramnik bien
profitent tout de suite de ce peut-être
de cette petite ce petit coup pour
proposer que la dame pénètre sur les
cases noires alors faut pas aller trop
vite évidemment maintenant
tour cédé 8
topalov mais maintenant une tour lui
aussi en vis-à-vis de la dame blanche
travnik en jouant dame g5 empêche ce
vis-à-vis fait ce dock louage sur
cavaliers qui peut faire un échange
d'armes et surtout bon il mais la dame
du côté roy sur l'occase noir donc en
profitant de l'affaiblissement mais le 4
mars essentiellement des bureaux à 6 si
je protège la cage des 5es jeux
peut-être je peut menacer maintenant le
coup c'est 5 c'est ça peut être l'idée
alors pas tout de suite peut-être on va
d'abord prendre des 4 et ensuite jouer
c'est simple puisque ses cinq tout de
suite se heurterait peut être à des cinq
fermeture des salles du centre pour les
blancs ce qui pourrait être embêtant
alors h3 puis on prend des quatre
cavaliers prendre des quatre dames 5 de
topalov known as tout simplement
échec et mat en rêve donc il faut faire
quelque chose d'en prendre 5
en échange les dames cavale et prend 1,5
et la chronique rapplique avec son
cavalier sur la case ces deux libérant
la colonne de sa tour et peut-être
proposant des échanges
la position est égale peut pas dire
qu'il ya un avantage leclerc d'un côté
ou de l'autre
hélas topalov vaut le coup j'ai cinq
alors un coup quand même un peu affaibli
stands il y avait déjà g6 qui affaiblit
c'est un peu le roi maintenant g520 coup
curieux il veut peut-être joué g4
topalov voilà son idée mais c'est un
coût qui semble un peu un peu affaibli
sent quand même du côté noir voilà
ou un coup dynamique emploi à la topalov
on a envie de dire donc il peut jouer
aussi hcng 4 voilà les possibilités mais
donc les dames sont échangés on est
presque dans une finale alors à noter
que cette case paris faible aussi quand
même ici
donc le travail pourrait à tout moment
joué en 3 et sur la case f5 avec un joli
cavaliers aussi voilà une possibilité
aussi pour les langues tout de suite qu
rami qui joue d'abord fou c'est un
attaquant le tout de suite le pion g5
qui n'est pas défendu
est-ce que j'ai 4 est possible sans
doute
topalov pourrait jouer le coup j'ai
quatre voilà maintenant c'est sûr
qu'après h prend les quatre tout
simplement peut noter que ses pions
deviennent faibles ils deviennent un peu
isolé la structure de pions noirs est
pas terrible donc topal choisit plutôt
de jouer le coup plus solides h6 ici
protégeant de simplement voilà
exactement protégeant le pion évitant de
casser sa structure fouet trois ans
qu'on le vit en live ses cinq ça y est
c'est l'heure donc on l'avait dit tout à
l'heure une fois que le plan des 4 est
sorti ses cinq deviennent d'actualité
pourquoi pour libérer ce couple et 7 ce
fameux fou bessette qu'on avait mis
c'est toujours dans l'idée de cette de
cette défense semi slave
si le foot en baisse est évidemment
c'est le libérer tôt ou tard par la
poussée c5 est ici tout de suite et bien
sa menace le pion aux 4 on va même ce
pion est attaqué et défendu qu'une seule
fois d'où le coup de chroniques f3 tout
simplement voilà je m'étonne mon pions
les quatre tranquille mais j'avais bien
peu les quatre mois bon ça peut être un
thème attention quand même
cavaillon agissent elles contrôleraient
beaucoup de cases aussi un noir mais il
n'y a pas de gros danger pour un roi qui
est quand même bien protégés il n'y a
pas de dames sur l'échiquier
c'est solide faut ensuite nos topalov
proposant un échange de tout en full web
de deux chroniques et maintenant fous
ces 8
une fois que ce fou a constaté que le
pion leucate est complètement bétonné
par le pion à f3 eh bien il est temps de
recycler ce fou sur notre diagonale donc
il veut très certainement mettre son fou
sur la case de 6 ici pour le recycler
donc il a vu que ce travail sur cette
diagonale là ne pouvait plus porter de
fruits car lille 3-2 kramnik alors on
l'avait dit on à la classe f 5 qui était
faible
c'est aussi l'idée des coûts s'est vite
c'est le protéger et aussi de protéger
la case des cinq puisque maintenant ce
sont les cavaliers qui menacent
d'envahir cette case protégé par la tour
faut 6 voilà et quand même maintenant
cavalier des cinq menace tout simplement
qu'elle allait prendre cavaliers échec
au roi et gagnent deux tours derrière
c'est une res direct vous prend
cavaliers et maintenant cramique en
profite pour jouer le coup je prends des
cinq qui lui donne déjà un pion passé
centrale à leurs problèmes
quand même sur ce plan passe et on
pourrait voir par exemple que les noirs
pourrait tenter de le gagner avec des
quatre attaquants lecavalier et on voit
que ce pion après ne sera plus défendu
puisqu'il sera attaqué deux fois mais
mais mais il ya une combinaison on va la
voir tout de suite après cavalier e 4
imaginons par exemple car il prend des
cinq as le pion est protégé par la tour
mais c'est pas grave on fait quand même
tout reprend cavaliers et après tout
reprend tour et bien cavaliers f6 échec
au roi est alors triple fourchette je
vais récupérer là tout en fait
3 les sets et après car les plantes aux
enfants on se rend compte qu'on a trois
pièces mineurs contre 2 on a les tours c
étant équilibré et bien ça fait une
grosse pièce de plus c'est pas possible
donc après eux prendre les 5 et bien des
quatre est pas vraiment un bon coup
puisque ça affaiblir et à la structure
des pions noirs
on voit bien que le groupe b4 affaiblir
et la casse ces quatre bien sous
contrôle du fou et du pion qui peut
servir pour soutenir le pion des cinq
donc on n'a pas intérêt à jouer ce genre
de coups sauf évidemment si le pion
dessin qui était gagnant mais ce n'est
pas le cas donc cavalier e 17
donc il revient en défense notre ami
notre ami topalov tour prend huit tours
prend 1,8 alors cette émission sera un
peu plus longue que les autres
évidemment il ya quatre parties à voir
et là maintenant à 4 voilà tout
simplement ici attaque le plan b 5 donc
ça c'est classique quand on a deux pions
ici face à troyes on va essayer de faire
maximum des changes
et puis de d'essayer de prendre le pion
isolé qui restera on a un gros pions
passé centrale y tient en plus ici le
pont on joue avec le fou pour attaquer
pion à 6 évidemment donc si on prend un
camion prend 1,4 qui aura une faiblesse
ici et après on aura gagné 1,15 c4 donc
on veut gagner a cassé quatre en jouant
ce coup là c'est normal on veut soutenir
votre pion une autre qui ont passé on
peut dire que là il ya quand même un
petit avantage blanc du film un gros
avantage langue qui est due à la fois
aux pions passé et à la paire de fou on
a total of sais c'est un peu c'est un
peu mis en danger dans cette partie
après b4 voilà le pion à six semaines en
est en prison mais le cavalier est en
prise cavaliers ou 4 donc on peut se
permettre de perdre
puis on prend un pion prend tout reprend
un pion ici puisque on récupère à la fin
le pion à six car il prend le 4 f34
topalov choisi de ne pas prendre ici
mais de jouer cavalier pts 6 qui veut
prendre du cavalier topalov visiblement
et la chronique joue impeccablement
précis il joue le coup des six alors on
va le voir tout de suite
voilà des
6 voilà ça y est le pion est protégé par
la tour et aux menaces cramique de
pousser son pion au maximum très loin et
pour menacer de faire d'un meurtre ça a
l'air de la fois des dangereux mais déjà
on peut paraître espion imaginons deux
tours des vite pour essayer de se dire
j'attaquais mlle foule à tour tout
simplement le coup eux cinq protège le
pion passé avec un gros gros avantage
blanc attaque le cavalier en plus très
gros avantage des six est fort et ça
tout simplement ça met la pression sur
le sol qu'en noir cavaler prendre 4
quand même des noirs attaque le pion des
six avec le fou est aussi proposée
actuellement un échange du fou qui est
protégé la chronique ne se démonte pas
c'est le temps c'est leur pardon pour
jouer 17 attaques la tour et menace de
faire dame donc la place le coût pour
les noirs ces tours des 8es l'a déjà on
peut dire que topaloff est en grande
difficulté dans cette deuxième partie
rapide dudit partage après fou prend à
6,2 kramnik logique cramique récupère
son pion et maintenant il ya un gros
pions passé qui peut protéger
pardon par fou s'est vite par exemple
immobilisant la tour et on voit que ce
pion à maintenant menace d'aller à dame
donc gros avantage noir et on va voir
que crâne il va pas laisser passer
l'occasion après f5
il met tout de suite en avant sa
majorité à 5 2 pions le passé ici
comment la tour peut à la fois arrêter
ce pion et celui ci on va voir que c'est
pas possible tu peux pas leur dire quand
même essayer quelque chose fou j'ai cet
échec au roi de chroniques
l'idée c'est de libérer ses pions pour
qu'il avance le plus vite possible
roy et fuite maintenant à six mois ça y
est on menace à sept à huit tours prend
et ensuite dame
alors ici topalov choisi de faire
cavaler prend fou reprend fouet
maintenant fou des quatre échecs
dernière tentative
on va voir que
ça va être terminé n'ont pu signer en
régie qu'on pourra pas faire les quatre
émissions mais on pourra faire les
quatre partis mais que deux dans celle
ci comprend vers les 2 juste après dans
une autre émission fou des quatre échecs
ici on voit que c'est un bon coup qui a
l'air en quinze années seul coup qui a
l'air bon puisque ça fait échec au roi
mais le pion ici et le pion ici qui
n'est plus protégé par la tour alors
c'est pourquoi kramnik joue le sommeil
qui gagne tout reprend fou tout
simplement sacrifie entre guillemets on
va voir que c'est pas un grand grand
sacrifice puisque après pions prendre
pour tout simplement on joue à 7
et voilà la tour ne peut pas prendre le
pion puisque sinon aux frais dames et on
voit que le prochain coup de crâne il
tout simplement ça va être fou des 5 et
menaçant dame on va voir qu'après trois
ou sept fous des cinq rois prend pion à
huit dames topalov joue encore tout
reprend à 8 et après fou prend à 8,2
cramique abandonne il a deux pions plus
évidemment topalov mais face à un fou
c'est impossible on peut pas on peut pas
lutter
le fou contrôle très très bien cette
avancée de pions le roi valet gober très
facilement un de ses deux pions on va
immobiliser les noirs on va faire un
zoom et on va prendre tous les pions et
faire dame pour gagner tranquillement
voilà donc très belle très belle
deuxième partie pour cramique donc email
qui mène d'un point dans cette
dans cette partie dans ce dense et des
partages pardon donc on va voir dans une
deuxième mission qui va suivre on le
fait en direct que vous dis c'est
aujourd'hui que ça s'est terminé
on va voir les deux dernières parties de
ce championnat du monde les deux
dernières semi rapide de ce championnat
du monde donc à très vite
oh